depuis aujourd'hui la ville de bordeaux
accueillent le plus grand bateau de
croisière de cette saison à ces
dernières années bordeaux redeviens un
port d'escale un port en rivière à 100
km de l'océan eric paiera clinique du
mari ce matin en se réveillant bordeaux
comptait deux bâtiments de plus amarré
en plein coeur de la ville deux
paquebots immense tout juste arrivé le
crystal serenity 250 mètres de long
mille sept cents passagers et membres
d'équipage des passagers qu'il faut
choyer alors dès l'aube la logistique
terrestre est en place
les cards excursions les voitures avec
chauffeurs les voitures de location car
la région ne manque pas d'arguments ce
groupe a opté pour la visite de
saint-émilion l'une des villes les plus
célèbres au monde grâce à son vignes les
claques c'est dans la boîte pour cette
clientèle en majorité américaines tout
est source d'émerveillement escale au
château prayssac ou pour la petite
histoire fut signé la fin de la bataille
de castillon aux 14 153 certes guerre de
cent ans ça ne dit pas grand chose à ses
touristes mais peu importe l'essentiel
est de voir un saint-émilion grand cru
et de le goûter
j'ai beaucoup plus appuyé sur le vin ici
est que lors de mes visites en
californie
à ces merveilleux
si romantique surenchérit charles et des
touristes heureux ce sont des touristes
qui dépensent magasins restaurants
activités portuaires ses escales sont
une bonne affaire pour la région sur la
dernière effectivement on était autour
de 35 millions d'euros environ sur
l'ensemble des retombées
20 escales cette saison bordeaux renoue
avec un prestigieux passé car dans les
années 20 avec cinquante mille passagers
par an la ville était le troisième port
français principal point de départ vers
l'amérique let certes les temps ont
changé plus qu'un moyen de transport le
bateau de croisière est aujourd'hui un
objet de loisir de luxe cette suite
royale avec grand lit et ben jacuzzi
coup 37000 euros pour 12 jours si
bordeaux séduit ses riches passagers
c'est parce qu'elle est l'une des rares
au monde à offrir une escale en plein
centre-ville de belles vacances pour
monsieur hublot